what we're going to do in this video is
quickly review exponential growth and
then use that as our platform to
introduce ourselves to exponential decay
so let's review exponential growth let's
say we have something that I'll do this
on a table here let's let me make that
straight so let's say this is our X and
this is our Y now let's say when X is
zero Y is equal to three and every time
we increase X by one we double Y so Y is
going to go from three to six if x
increases by 1 again so we go to 2 then
we're going to double Y again and so 6
times 2 is 12 this right over here is
exponential growth and you can even go
for negative X's when X is negative 1
well if we're going back 1 and X we
would divide by 2 so this is going to be
three halves 3 halves
I notice if you go from negative 1 to 0
you once again you keep multiplying by 2
and this will keep on happening and you
can describe this with an equation you
could say that Y is equal to and
sometimes people might call this your
y-intercept or your initial value is
equal to 3 essentially what happens when
x equals 0 is equal to 3 times our
common ratio and a common ratio is well
what are we multiplying by every time we
increase X by 1 so 3 times our common
ratio 2 to the to the X to the X power
and you can verify that pick any of
these when X is equal to 2 it's going to
be 3 times 2 squared which is 3 times 4
which is indeed equal to 12 and we can
see that on a graph so let me draw a
quick graph right over here so I'm
having trouble drawing a straight line
all right there we go and let's see we
could go and they're going to be on the
slightly different scale my x and y axes
so this is x axis y axis and we go from
negative 1/2
- one two - yes we're going all the way
up to 12 so let's say that this is three
six nine and let's say this is twelve
and we could just plot these points here
when X is negative 1 Y is 3 has so looks
like that then at y equals 0 X when x is
0 Y is 3 when x equals 1 y has doubled
it's now at 6 when X is equal to 2 y is
12 and you will see this telltale curve
and so there's a couple of key features
that we've what we've already talked
about several of them but if you go to
increasingly negative x values you will
ask asymptotes towards the x axis it'll
never quite get to 0 as you get to more
and more negative values but it'll
definitely approach it as you get to
more and more positive values it just
kind of skyrockets up we always we've
talked about in previous videos how this
will pass up any linear function or any
linear graph eventually now let's
compare that to exponential decay
exponential exponential decay an easy
way to think about it instead of growing
every time you're increasing X you're
going to shrink by about load by a
certain amount you are going to decay so
let's set up another table here with x
and y values that was really a very I'm
supposed to distance opposed to what I
press shift it should create a straight
line but my my computer I've been eating
next to my computer maybe there's crumbs
in the keyboard or something okay so
here we go we have X and we have Y and
so let's start with let's say we start
in the same place so when x is 0 Y is 3
but instead of doubling every time we
increase X by 1 let's go by half every
time we increase X by 1 so when X is
equal to 1 we're going to multiply by
1/2 and so we're going to get to
three-halves and then when x is equal to
2 we'll multiply by 1/2 again and so
we're going to get 2/3
we're going to get to three forts and so
on and so forth and if we were to go to
negative values when X is equal to
negative one well to go if we're going
backwards in X by one we would divide by
one half and so we would get to six or
going from negative one to zero as we
increase X by one
once again we're multiplying we're
multiplying by 1/2 and so how would we
write this as an equation I encourage
you to pause the video and see if you
can write it in a similar way well it's
going to look something like this
it's going to be y is equal to you have
your you could you can have your y
intercept here the value of y when x is
equal to zero so it's three times what's
our common ratio now well every time we
increase X by one we're multiplying by
1/2 so 1/2 and we're going to raise that
to the X power and so notice these are
both Exponential's we have some you
could say y-intercept or initial value
and it's being multiplied by some common
ratio to the power X some common ratio
to the power X but notice when you're
growing our common ratio and it actually
turns out to be a general idea when
you're growing your common ratio the
absolute value of your common ratio is
going to be greater than one let me
write it in so the absolute value of 2
in this case is greater than 1 but when
you're shrinking the absolute value of
it is less than 1 and that makes sense
because it's the if you have something
where the absolute value is less than 1
like 1/2 or 3/4 or 0.9 every time you
multiply it you're going to get a lower
and lower and lower value and you could
actually see that in a graph let's graph
the same information right over here and
let me do it in a different color I'll
do it and I'll do it in a blue color so
when X is equal to negative 1 y is equal
to 6 when X is equal to 0 Y is equal to
3 when X is equal to 1 Y is equal to 3
halves when X is equal to 2 y is equal
to 3/4 and so on and so forth and notice
because our common ratios are the
reciprocal of each other that these two
graphs
look like they've been flipped over they
look like they've been flipped
horizontally or flipped over the y-axis
they're symmetric around that y-axis and
what you'll see an exponential decay is
that things will get smaller and smaller
and smaller but they'll never quite
exactly get to zero it'll approach zero
it'll ask them to towards the x axis as
X becomes more and more positive just as
for exponential growth if X becomes more
and more more negative we asked them to
towards the x axis so that's the
introduction I do is a very specific
example but in general if you have an
equation of the form y is equal to a
times some common ratio to the X power
we could write it like that just to make
it a little bit clearer well just a
bunch of different ways that we could
write it this is going to be exponential
growth so if the absolute value of R is
greater than 1 then we're dealing with
growth because every time you multiply
every time you increase extra melt your
multiplying by more and more ours is one
way to think about it and if the
absolute value of R is less than 1
you're dealing with decay you are
shrinking as x increases and I'll let
you think about what happens when what
happens when R is equal to 1 what are we
dealing with in that situation and it's
a bit of a trick question because it's
actually quite straight I'll just tell
you if R is equal to 1 well then this
thing right over here is always going to
be equal to 1 and you boil down to just
the constant equation y is equal to a so
this would just be a horizontal line